I loved you in Mad Max but you were
fantastic and it was a nice experience
for you because you not only gave an
amazing performance but you also met
your husband that's right that's so cool
your husband and I didn't know this
your husband was doof warrior hanging
off the front of the Mad Max and I was
thinking how did you see that guy put
that picture up again how did you see
that guy and go that's the guy for me
Wow I heard you dressed up as my husband
I did we did for we when we went to
comic-con was this now two years ago now
right Andy and I did an open where Andy
you were driving the truck yeah I was
and I was in front and we were on our
way to say Mort Andrew yeah driving the
truck and I'm was doof warrior I did my
version and let's see if maybe you'll
find I'll show the picture see if you
find me more attractive
[Applause]
they yep which one's worse he made which
one's sexier yeah when you met him he
had he had like filed a writ but I mean
he he was in all this makeup and
everything when did you get to really
meet him well I actually didn't meet him
until we did reshoots which was like a
year later and I was in costume wasn't
in costume his head was shaved but he
was wearing regular clothes yeah well he
was when I came into your dressing room
to say hi he was there I he's like one
of the best-looking people I've ever
seen and that was just funny it's like
that's the do for you
you